climate change now the continent and its
massive amounts of ice are offering
valuable clues about global warming John
Blackstone has taken a ten thousand mile
trip back to discover the secrets
contained in the ice and under it for
our series journey to the bottom of the
earth at the South Pole it's 48 degrees
below zero on a typical summer day
welcome to the Earth's air conditioner
Antarctica holds 90% of the Earth's ice
7 million cubic miles of it here at the
South Pole the enormity of the Antarctic
Ice Sheet is striking beneath me the ice
is 2 miles thick and this ice sheet
stretches over an area as large as the
United States and Mexico combined it's
ice so thick it buries entire Antarctic
mountain ranges it's so cold at the
South Pole the snow never melts it just
turns to ice and gets thicker the
secrets of that ice are now coming into
focus me the really cool thing about
Antarctica is the bubbles in it those
bubbles are samples of the Earth's
ancient atmosphere trapped in the ice
for Ken Taylor the ice is like a library
stacked with climate records going back
thousands of years he expects his ice
core samples will confirm a key argument
in global warming current levels of
greenhouse gases are much higher than
they've been at any time for the last
650,000 years and it's all due to human
activity when CBS News last visited here
in 1999 the geodesic dome of the
American science station was already
disappearing under the snow now there's
a new state of the art station for
dozens of scientists and support workers
it's on stilts so it can be raised as
the snow builds around it no one owns
the South Pole but the American presence
here makes a subtle point about who's in
charge discouraging the kind of
competing land grabs currently happening
at the North Pole where Russia even sent
a submarine to plant its flag in the
ocean floor beneath the pole this
station represents the US presence and
playing a key role in scientific
research to
to understand our planet better so the
National Science Foundation is funding
ambitious experiments here well other
science budgets are getting cut this 272
million dollar telescope drilled into
the ice is looking down it detects
neutrinos powerful particles from space
that travel right through the earth and
may reveal how the universe was formed
as a chance that this is this telescope
here we're gonna have great discoveries
that no one will have been able to
predict or immediate discoveries are
coming under the ice in the ocean around
Antarctica from penguins
to fish with antifreeze in their blood
this is one of the last largely
undisturbed ecosystems on earth and it's
filled with unusual creatures I find
interesting about this guy is that his
shells on the insides if you squish them
you squishy on the outside and crunchy
on the inside that somehow survives when
they should be freezing there's a lot of
things that these organisms can do which
would be really great for us to be able
to understand and apply to human biology
like how doctors can use cold fluids to
keep critically ill patients alive cool
science from a frozen continent John
Blackstone CBS News at the South Pole
and tomorrow as we continue our journey
to the bottom of the earth the perils of
frozen trash that has been there for
over a century and that is the CBS
Evening News I'm Katie Couric we thank
the single sponsor of tonight's
broadcast and of course we thank you for
watching good night
you